Recent vaccine trial results have been cause for
optimism that we can combat the COVID-19 pandemic.
But how confident can we be in these results?
Pharmaceutical company Pfizer announced that their
vaccine is 95% effective. This result is based off
of clinical trials that had 43,000 participants.
But what happens when this vaccine is given to
the broader population? Well, based on statistics,
we can conclude that there is a 99 in 100 chance
that the Pfizer vaccine has a true efficacy rate
above 90%. What does that mean? A 95% efficacy rate
means that one out of every 21 positive cases
in the trial are in the vaccinated group. If we
apply these odds independently to each of the 170
positive cases in the trial, there is a 1 in 100
chance of observing 15 or more vaccinated cases,
which is the same as a 90% efficacy rate. After a
long battle against COVID-19, the end is in sight.
Continuing to gather data is a must, but
vaccine optimism is certainly not misplaced.
Would you take a 95% effective
vaccine? Let us know in our poll.
Also, let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to like and subscribe
for more research and videos from AEI.